Hello, how are you, Héctor Mejía greeting you with
his new newsletter? Today is Thursday,
May 6. For the first time in history, a
teacher from Nevada is
nationally recognized as teacher of the year.
Julián A Urtubey was surprised by the
civil network this morning. She teaches
prekindergarten through fifth grade.  degree at
carmen walker elementary school located at martin
luther king iii care and she has her
bachelor of art in
bilingual elementary education and a
doctorate from the university of
arizona first lady joe biden is
in las vegas today she
she shared with the johns hospital team
and to thank them for everything
they did during the pandemic she
was also accompanied by members
of the international union of employees
james words continues with her
job fair today from 9 a.m.
to 4 p.m.  the afternoon inside
the mandalay bay convention center the
company is looking for staff for
different departments for a list
full list of jobs you can visit
our kirchner dotcom
diagonal page in spanish
we go to your weather forecast
another warm day awaits us after the
mid 90 degrees we had
yesterday we will have breezes coming from the
south for today thursday with temperatures in
the high nineties  we will also have
gusts of 30 miles per hour have a
nice thursday i am héctor mejía and this
was your short informative edition in
spanish